we just got 100 confirmation through
brand new leaks that Apple's M3 chip
isn't coming until the fall of this year
the only problem with that is that the
15-inch MacBook gear is coming in June
at Apple's WWDC event but with an M2
Chip instead so the big question I'm
gonna answer in this video is why Apple
would do this when the M3 is right
around the corner how are they going to
get away with this the answer actually
makes a whole lot of sense so let's jump
right into it now the first thing I want
to cover is the exclusive leak from nine
to five Mac back in March saying that
both the 13 and 15 inch MacBook Air will
be using M3 chips and they even
suggested that there's a chance they
could be coming at WWDC and that report
from 95 Mac was directly going against
other leaks and rumors that pointed to
the 15-inch coming sooner with an M2 jet
for example digit times of all sources
back in February said the 15-inch will
reportedly have an M2 Chip and that was
a couple of months ago when nobody
believed him we also had Ross young
saying that production of 15-inch
MacBook Air components were underway
with a WWDC launch looking very likely
and then just last week Mark German came
out and said that the 15-inch MacBook
Air was coming at WWDC with an M2 like
chip whatever that means basically he
looked at the developer logs and that
chip had an 8 core CPU and a 10 core GPU
and 8 gigs of RAM just like the M2 Chip
but still at that time he did not say it
would be an M2 just M2 like and then
just this morning as I'm recording this
right now we had a report from a Korean
blogger which is
yoix1122 out of know how to pronounce
that but that's who he is he was
actually the same person who leaked the
notch on the MacBook Pro so I believe in
him he says that the 15 inch is gonna
feature the M2 Chip and Dan neistead
posted on Twitter that Apple has delayed
their plans to introduce the M3 chip
based on three nanometer technology and
will instead use the M2 for the upcoming
15-inch air basically saying that the
three nanometer chip revenue for tsmc is
coming later in the third quarter and
then finally after that Mark German
confirmed yes the 15-inch is getting the
M2 for sure not the M3 and that came at
the same time as Ming shukuo said the
15-inch is getting the M2 with two
different chip options no M2 Pro
configuration and what that basically
means is you're gonna have a bin chip
with one less Graphics core and then an
unbend M2 Chip just like we have with
the current 13-inch MacBook Pro and he
also confirmed that the production of
the M3 chip is anticipated to begin and
the second half of this year pointing to
a fall release slightly ahead of M3 Pro
and M3 Max which will likely come about
six months after the regular M3 and then
on top of all of that tsmc just reported
their earnings and they confirmed that
the three nanometer N3 chip Revenue will
only begin in the third quarter
basically confirming that the M3 chip is
not coming until the fall likely after
the a17 ship in September that's also
going to be based on three nanometer
then only later in October or November
that's when we're gonna get the M3 chip
and all of that basically confirms what
digit times said way back in January
that a new Macbook Air with a three
nanometer M3 chip is rumored to launch
in the second half of
2023. it's kind of funny that digit
times used to get laughed at but now
they are correct and they were the first
ones to call it so with that said now
that we have confirmation that the
15-inch MacBook Air is coming at WWDC
with an M2 Chip here is my personal
prediction that 15 inch is gonna to be
identical to the current 13-inch M2
redesigned model except for basically
three differences the larger 15 inch
display a larger battery which will give
it the best battery life in any MacBook
ever which is how Apple's gonna Market
it and larger speaker enclosures for
probably better bass and volume in terms
of speaker quality and maybe blue 5.3
and Wi-Fi 6E as well but other than that
it's going to be identical and it's
simply going to be 200 more expensive
than the 13 inch model you're paying for
the larger size so with that said why in
the world would Apple give the brand new
15-inch MacBook Air the old M2 Chip just
six months before giving the M3 to the
13 inch well I have three very good
reasons that explain everything the
first reason is that the 15 inch with an
M3 chip would directly threaten the
sales of the two thousand dollar M2 Pro
MacBook Pro 14 inch and the main reason
for that is because I estimated the
performance of the M3 chip and it would
likely outperform the base Bend tan core
M2 Pro chip model so why would you pay
two thousand dollars for a 14 inch when
you can pay a thousand four hundred for
a bigger 15 inch display and a faster M3
chip giving it the older M2 would put
the whole lineup into balance and make
it clear that the 14 inch M2 Pro is
better and now for reason number two
apple has a massive surplus of M2 chips
that just aren't selling and in order to
sell through their stock they're going
to be making a couple of extra Max with
M2 chips including the 15 inch MacBook
Air and how do I know this well we
recently got a report that Apple's Max
sales dropped 40 percent compared to
last year the worst drop in 23 years and
the way we know they have a massive
Surplus is because Apple literally
stopped M2 Chip production entirely for
two whole months in January and February
and when they resume production in March
it was cut in half compared to previous
years and now now we have reason number
three for why apple is giving the 15
inch an M2 Chip Apple's Mac chips are
clearly on a 1.5 year update cycle
compared to Apple's a series chips which
get updated every single year so even if
Apple could have had the M3 chip ready
on time for WWDC they wouldn't anyway
because it hasn't been one and a half
years yet and the main point of this is
to allow the current mship more time to
sell and allow their Engineers more time
to work on future M chips so apple is
essentially stretching the life cycle of
their Mac Generations which is a very
smart business move so there you go
those were the three reasons why it
actually makes sense for Apple to give
the 15-inch MacBook Air and M2 Chip now
of course that sucks for us consumers
because if they gave it the M3 you would
essentially get a fourteen hundred
dollar 15 inch MacBook Air here with a
very fast M3 chip that's faster than the
base 14 inch MacBook Pro for two
thousand dollars that would be amazing
but of course apple does not want to
cannibalize their higher end MacBook Pro
lineup and because of that they're
giving us the 15 inch with the M2 Chip
to sell off that huge surplus of those
chips so hopefully that explained it for
all of you guys if you completely
disagree with my take let me know down
in the comment section below click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]